créée en 2015 dans le but de limiter la
propagation de la grippe le air clean de
sang a également prouvé son efficacité
en tant de kovy 19 son action est rendu
possible grâce à un réacteur testé et
approuvé par plusieurs centres de
recherche dont le cnrs donc là je vous
faire voir l'éclaté de la machine avec
son fonctionnement
donc là en fait l'air est aspiré par un
ventilateur
freiner dans notre réacteur qui lui ont
bombardé de l'ue vers et après l'or
l'air ressort des contaminés on a mis un
petit filtre devant mais c'est
simplement pour le atténué en fait la
luminosité de l'avant et pour des
raisons de sécurité et d'environnement
une lampe uv a est utilisé plus vert
pourquoi parce que les uv c aujourd'hui
génère de l'ozone donc s'ils ont des
contamines avec un duvet c'est les
personnes peuvent pas rester dans la
pièce alors qu'avec notre équipement
vous pouvez décontaminer toute la
journée les personnes peuvent rester
dans la pièce le décontaminateur air
clean de s'en est vendu à 550 euros hors
taxes principalement à destination des
lieux de fort passage écoles ou ehpad